this is olive
or aliveka technically she's
eight weeks old i think what's up
you want to say it hey what's up guys my
name is echerno
no you know what you want to say it
hey what's up guys my name is the
channel welcome back to another hazel
devlog
it's been a while hasn't it don't worry
i am still working on hazel
every time i don't post one of these
videos people assume that i've abandoned
the project or disappeared somewhere or
just just
run away no i'm still here that's
i'm still here you're stuck with me
amongst some stuff going on in my
personal life don't worry nothing
bad and wanting to take a little bit of
a break as well as just
taking a step back from some videos and
thinking about what it is i'm actually
doing with like hazel and
my life all of this meant that there
were just not many
videos coming out on my channel but
hopefully we're going to be back into
the swing of things
starting from roundabout now for quite a
while and i've said this before but i've
been feeling like i've been ping-ponging
between two different
careers like a software engineer working
on a game engine and then this kind of
media video creator called the churno
truth is i'm kind of
obviously both of those things and
sometimes i feel like one of those parts
needs more education which is why
sometimes you'll see me put out more
videos
and do less work on hazel sometimes
you'll see me do more work on hazel and
put out less videos and the latter is
exactly what has happened over the last
couple weeks there are always certain
things that i
should be working on for hazel in fact
i've made a road map there'll be a link
to it in the description below you can
check it out but the fact of the matter
is
sometimes i get distracted by wanting to
do something that i'm actually
passionate about for those of you who
know me
most of my passion with computer science
and programming comes from graphics i
really like graphics and rendering
and so one day while working on what i
was supposed to be working on
for dev i thought hmm wouldn't this
scene just look so much better with
shadows and down the rabbit hole
i went for those of you who don't know
shadows real time
shadows dynamic shadows are like one of
the worst things in
modern rendering not too modern though
we're not talking about ray tracing
because that stuff is that stuff is
i'm talking about traditional kind of
shadow mapping techniques they are just
the worst
there's there's no way there's no better
way to describe them shadow mapping is
just the worst
because it's not stable it doesn't work
for all cases there's always certain
things that that are just
a shame it's not a real it's not a
proper way to actually calculate light
because the proper way
which is ray tracing is just too
expensive you can't just bounce rays
around
infinitely because well performance
offline rendered shadows
always look better because they have
time to actually compute the way that
light works properly
that's why even in 2020 you know we
still
use static lighting we still bake light
maps from other software
that can actually take the time to work
out where the light is supposed to go
and where the occlusion is so therefore
where the shadow should be
of course this stuff isn't just for
shadows it's for other things like
ambient occlusion global elimination all
that kind of stuff
a lot of these lighting effects are just
really difficult to compute in real time
without using something like ray tracing
that's why what we end up with is a
whole bunch of cheat
methods or approximations and a lot of
them can actually look really good
until they don't i think shadow mapping
is a great example of this you can set
up a 4k shadow map
render you know the light from the
perspective of your scene and in certain
situations that will work
really well i mean if you have like a
spotlight and it's just got a nice
little small
range and you just place it their shadow
maps are fine you're not going to notice
a huge
huge kind of i guess reduction quality
there but when you picture a huge open
world a 3d scene
and you want to have a shadow map coming
in from the skylight you want a
directional light that's casting shadows
upon the entire world
that's really where a lot of the
problems begin and not just problems
of how on earth do i render this in
enough detail and still perform
adequately but also what do i do with
the edges how do i
filter them what about self shadowing
what about there's just so much
there's so much to consider it's it's
funny because i've never been a huge fan
of shadow mapping i
i specifically have avoided it for this
long because
i was legit like i'll be real with you
guys i was thinking if i give it a few
years
maybe i'll just be able to retrace it
but alas i i went down the rabbit hole
of shadows i shouldn't know i should
have just done what i was supposed to do
but sometimes the passion kicks in and
you just want to make the scene look
better
in my in my case and that's what i did
now the rabbit hole
of shadows actually started with me
being like okay shadow mapping is kind
of you know annoying let's do something
a little bit better what if i voxelized
the whole scene and
just you know did some cone tracing to
figure out what should be in shadow what
shouldn't be in shadow and then
also get some free gi while i'm at it
this was actually one of the first
things i tried so voxelizing the whole
scene basically rendering your scene
into like 3d textures and slices of
voxels essentially that are colored and
have information such as what's
including them
that stuff is great in theory but it
also suffers from the same
kind of problem that shadow maps do
apart from being
very expensive and a lot more expensive
than than shadow mapping
you also have the same problem of okay
but i need
all of the stuff that is around me stuff
is close to the camera i need to render
that in a higher quality
than stuff that's further away because i
don't care about that as much
but what if i'm standing on a hill and
looking out into the distance
i need that information to kind of be
there so what do i do
i can't generate an infinite amount of
voxels like that
i need to make some compromises and
those same compromises need to be made
for shadow mapping so very quickly after
i i think
briefly implemented some kind of soft
shadows with voxels i don't even
remember if i if i got all the way into
that before i abandoned it i realized
that this probably just isn't gonna be
worth it at least at this stage and
certainly not for
the amount of tweaking i'm gonna have to
do to make it look good so after that i
think i just
went with some pretty simple hard
shadows
this is cool this is feeling like an
actual development log i'm actually
going over what i did in the last two
weeks in my whole journey let me know if
you guys are interested more in this
kind of stuff
i looked through so many different
shadow mapping techniques
i mean i started with just normal kind
of pcf filtering i think i went to
uh variance shadow maps after that and
then exponential
shadow maps after that i did there's
just so many different
names and they all mean almost nothing
unless you actually look up what the
algorithm does what does
variance shadow mapping mean i think i
ultimately realized that i did
want soft shadows but i didn't just want
kind of
like make all my shadows soft no matter
what because that's
that doesn't really look very realistic
i wanted actual
actual kind of almost like contact
hardening shadow shadows that
the closer you are to the surface the
harder the shadow is because that's
that's how the real world works and i
think that's one of the coolest things
that you can actually implement i think
it almost
immediately makes your scene look a lot
better especially to someone who knows
what they're looking at so for that i
stumbled upon
two different nvidia algorithms and i
think one of them is like 15 years old
and the other one is a little bit newer
so pcss which is percentage closer
soft shadows and then also hybrid
frostum
soft shadows i think hybrid frost and
trace shadows which is basically where
you do like ray tracing with the shadows
but it's like with a frosted more with
triangles or something like that i don't
know
i didn't look into it too much because
it was as far as like as far as i could
tell there weren't really that many
open source implementations because it
is part of nvidia gameworks which is
like a third-party middleware
and then also it's extremely expensive i
think it just pretty much takes up like
90 of your render time or something
ridiculous it was just way too expensive
i wanted something that would perform
decently so i went back to pcss now
nvidia has a really cool paper on this
from like 2005
but let's be real reading papers and
implementing algorithms by yourself
in 2020 is a little bit of a drag unless
it's like a cutting-edge new algorithm
that no one has ever implemented and
you're like well i guess i guess i have
to don't get me wrong i love reading
papers and
i think that it's extremely important to
actually read a paper to figure out
what you're dealing with but the next
step should be to go to github and see
if you can find
some example code if you can find
someone's implementation
that is a fantastic starting point now
notice how i said starting point
that's because almost nothing at least
in my experience that i found on github
was just
perfect out of the box i mean don't get
me wrong people have made some really
nice implementations of pcss
some of them look better than others
some of them do things differently some
of them for example do the penumbra
calculation and the blocker kind of
uh you know finding the blockers of of
what includes the light and all that
stuff
some of them do that better than others
some of them do the actual filtering a
bit differently or better
some of them are implemented in a in not
a very good kind of performing way
some of them are more optimized it's
just there's just you know with the open
source community there's so much stuff
out there
and i think that it's really it's really
nice to be able to look at existing code
but then you have to look at it as
someone has just put this on github i
don't know who it is i don't know what
kind of quality of software this is
going to be
you know it's just on github that's
great it's going to be a huge help to me
most likely
but i'm going to have to probably just
change it quite a bit it's a lot easier
than trying to implement an algorithm
from a paper with absolutely no
reference whatsoever
and it's a lot faster than that as well
but i think
gone are the days where i could just
copy and paste some code slap it in and
then everything just works out of the
box and everything is perfect
there's usually a lot of tweaking or
rewriting or optimizing that needs to be
done
so i think in the end i ended up
i ended up looking at three or four
different pcss implementations on github
and kind of almost like vocal comping
whereas you know a singer like records
like a vocal track and then you pick the
best parts of everything and you kind of
composite it together
almost like that i kind of just picked
like you know someone's block research
implementation was fantastic
someone's filtering implementation was
fantastic i threw in some of my own code
as well to make some things a little bit
faster and just look a little bit nicer
and i think at that point i got
something that was looking decent
i mean i probably spent almost a day
going through a lot of different shadow
mapping algorithms on github downloading
the sample projects compiling them
looking at them and being like oh this
uh
this doesn't look good at all but then
finally with a little bit of playing
with it and actually understanding how
the algorithm works so i can you know
modify it and
fix it in some cases i finally got to
the point where i was really quite happy
with the result
except for the fact that all of the
algorithms that i looked at
were understandably just lighting
a little like model or a sphere or a
cube on a plane
that's it so so this isn't like some 3d
world
like an open world you know that is
fully just perfect like shadow solution
for a perfect open 3d world of infinite
scale
no this really only worked for your kind
of model
for like a model viewer essentially and
this is something that
i see a lot lots of people who are
writing their own engines or their own
games
will kind of maybe get to the point
where they start relying on
on like people's code off github a
little bit too much
because everything is so available right
why wouldn't you just
download someone's code from github slap
it in and everything's gonna work
perfectly
the thing is almost none of the samples
that you find
are scalable meaning that more than
likely
they're set up to just demo an algorithm
or demo a sample
in one of the simplest cases and that's
why almost all the samples you find
online are just
like essentially a model viewer there's
just like some you know physically based
rendering
sure but it's like one model in the
middle of the screen
and maybe like a ground plane or
something that's it that's not a game
that's not a scene riding a game engine
that can render an
entire scene that you can walk around
and interact with
and run across that is a completely
different story
to looking at like sasha willem's vulcan
examples and being like this is how you
write a vulcan renderer
absolutely no disrespect to such alums
by the way those those
those examples are mint but they're just
not really examples of like a scalable
game engine which is
understandable they're not supposed to
be oh man i haven't made a video on so
long i just feel like talking for hours
anyway i'm sorry let's get back to the
shadow stuff so long story short
all of the shadow mapping examples i
looked at and the way that they were set
up was just to render a single model but
obviously i need to be able to render a
whole scene i need to be able to render
a world that you can
run across and wherever you are you know
you should see shadows it should work
all across the world now a really
popular way to handle that is something
called cascaded shadow mapping
so what that means is that instead of
rendering a single shadow map and you
kind of try and you know position the
the shadow map in a way that that fits
your scene instead of doing that you
render three or four or potentially more
different shadow maps from increasingly
further out angles and it's not just
really increasingly further out angles
but basically what you do is you divide
the cameras frost them so whatever the
camera is looking at
into like three or four pieces and then
starting with the section that is
closest to what the camera is looking at
closest to the camera
and then it going increasingly further
and further away now what that allows
you to do
is basically zoom in your shadow
rendering into the part that's kind of
closest to the camera and then for the
stuff that's further away
you use a kind of less detailed more
zoomed out kind of shadow map because
obviously a frostum
you know the stuff that's closest to the
camera is the biggest it's what you're
looking at
it's physically bigger and the further
away from the camera you get the
more stuff fits onto the screen so
therefore you you kind of need to
render a larger shadow map but you don't
want to because if you do that then
you'll lose detail
someone who's never implemented shadow
mapping this probably doesn't make much
sense but just bear with me and then
also instead of just being like this is
my directional light i'm going to
focus it at you know the what the origin
of the world and just random shadow map
there
you also need to move everything with
the camera because there's no point in
rendering like part of a shadow map that
is
you know behind the camera you're never
going to use that you essentially want
to remove the shadow map rendering with
the camera
so i had to take all of the pcss stuff
that i did and then add
shadow cascades to that and then also
make it kind of fit the cameras frost
them so that we could look around
and you know wherever we were we would
see shadows and also
implement some kind of shadow distance
and i ended up doing a lot of tweaking
and a lot of
extra implementation on top of all of
this to actually make the shadows look
as good as possible
and still they're nowhere near done and
i'm just going to kind of move off of
this for now because it's just it's
taking too much time i need to do other
stuff unfortunately i can't
do shadows full time but for now i think
they're fine i've
i've kept the option for hard shadows as
well just in case you want that extra
performance but overall it was a
super fun two weeks i did a little bit
of live streaming yesterday as well on
twitch tv slash the channel where i
kind of spent some time refining the
shadow mapping and just making it a
little bit better just tweaking the
shaders all of that kind of stuff
and i think it's finally gotten to the
point where i feel comfortable showing
you guys now
that's another thing that i've been
thinking about a lot these are devlogs i
probably should show
my shadow mapping failing as well
because if i just show
everything being good and you don't see
the hours
of me pulling my hair out then maybe
that's not a good look for what it's
really like to build a game engine
believe me
it's not all rainbows and butterflies
but anyway let's jump in
to the to hazel and we'll take a look at
that also i've added some other like
i've added light components release
directional light component i had
something called a skylight
you know well i'll show you i'll show
you what i'm talking about but we might
revisit this stuff in
a later episode as well in more detail
okay so opening up hazelnut we are
created with this kind of black
scene it's got a very simple entity here
that has a kind of a scene model it's
it's like this box and then like another
box on top of it and there's also a
sphere in the scene that is actually
quite small so this scene at the moment
has no lighting i've revamped the entire
lighting system so
if there are no lights this is what you
see now in the future there might be
some kind of like editor lighting
situation but this is essentially
pretend the lighting for this is runtime
lighting
even though we're using an editor camera
and we don't actually have a camera
entity in our scene
the lighting is still being calculated i
guess as if it was completely done
um as part of the run time so we need to
add some lights
so there are two different types of
lights here i've created like a bit of a
better context menu so that we don't
have to create an empty entity and then
add all the components to it
so we have two at the moment we've got a
directional light and a skylight
now a directional light is what you
might expect it's just a directional
light and this is what it looks like
this is these are the default shadow
settings and this is what you see and
we'll go into
more depth about that in a minute but
then you've also got a skylight now this
i kind of took inspiration from unreal
engine because i needed some way to put
my ibl my kind of environment map
uh and i noticed that they do it by
essentially just creating a skylight and
then you can set like an environment map
in there
so if i create a new skylight and then
open up
a environment map like birchwood for
example it's an hdr file
this is what our scene now looks like
with both a skylight and a directional
light
now you can remove the directional light
and then this is just going to be
ambient lighting from
the skylight no directional light at all
and
as we don't have any kind of like
ambient occlusion or anything like that
there are obviously there's not going to
be any kind of shading or shadows
whatsoever
okay let's create the directional light
back and this is what the scene looks
like
now it's looking a little bit bright uh
there's a few reasons for this and
there's a few ways that you can
control this the skylight actually has
an intensity
this is like the contribution multiplier
i guess of the actual ibl calculation
for the pbr shader so you can actually
just drop that to zero and now
it won't contribute any ibl this is as
if we just removed
the skylight altogether and then we can
kind of add a little bit maybe and
obviously add a lot if we want to as
well
so that's one way that we can play
around with that but then also we have a
camera exposure
since this is not um the actual runtime
scene with the camera entity
the environment panel at the moment has
a few controls that are specific
to the actual kind of scene editor
camera
so i can just drop the exposure a little
bit and then you'll see that we won't be
quite so overexposed this is kind of
what the scene
looks like now one thing that i forgot
to add before this video actually into
the directional light properties
was the um color or the radiance of the
light so
there used to be like a light radiance
here that at the moment does nothing
um so i forgot to add that but anyway it
doesn't matter there'll be a light
radiance there
and in fact all of this obviously is
very much work in progress so i'm going
to be tweaking this
a lot so we have a few options for
the directional light obviously we can
control the direction and that's as
simple as just
uh you know opening up the gizmo or
playing with the transformation of the
light
in general but then also we have cast
shadows soft shadows and source size
i believe these two don't do anything at
the moment because they're controlled
globally as we'll see in a minute
uh but cast shadows of course will
either cast shadows or not cast shadows
let's make this a little bit bigger
maybe
and move it somewhere else and then we
can see the result
of enabling shadows and not so let's
talk a little bit about the different
shadow types that we have
so if i open up this temporary scene
renderer
um panel i guess which just contains
some exposed variables and like the
shadow map texture as well from the
scene renderer
we have soft shadows and hard shadows so
um there is a bit of a performance
difference where's my little performance
thing
uh here it is so if i bring this over
here just says how many milliseconds we
have per frame and i've turned vsync off
of course
so uh soft shadows is you can see three
to four milliseconds for this scene and
then if i
turn that off it's quite a bit faster
0.8 or some milliseconds with heart
shadows
so that's just something to keep in mind
uh soft shadows will cost more
of course um and we have a few
kind of parameters here that you can
tweak so light size
is a good example if i just drop this to
zero then it's
basically hard shadows hard shadows that
cost the same as soft shadows so if i
kind of enable that and disable that at
the moment the way that the shader works
is they look identical but this one
costs a lot more performance so if
you're after this kind of look then shut
off
soft shadows and this is something that
you'll be able to do perlite in the
future
um so yeah if we obviously increase that
you can see that the shadow gets more
and more soft
i think 0.5.25 is probably a good kind
of
amount and you can always tweak that per
light as well in the future so it's
something that probably
um maybe i'll i'll change the way that
the sampling works because obviously if
we have
a softer light we need more samples than
if we have a harder light because
there's just you can get away with
doing less samples since there's just
not that much of an area
um so let me quickly add just a mesh
here
i'll add a and at the moment even if
we're loading just a simple cube we
still have to
kind of load it like that so if i move
this over here this will demonstrate
what i was talking about about
the fact that the light will be softer
based on how far away
the object is from the surface so if we
kind of move this down a little bit
uh you should be able to see this is a
terrible position for it isn't it
um that the light or the shadow that is
closer
to the actual um you know where this uh
i guess
object actually hits okay that was a
terrible explanation
the closer the object is to the shadow
the harder the shadow is so as i move
over here you can see the shadow gets
progressively softer which is exactly
the effect that we're after
obviously with hard shadows we don't
have anything like that whatsoever and
it just
looks hard everywhere which is is fine i
mean
a lot of games look like that and it's
it's totally okay but these days of
course
we're more used to seeing graphics like
this um
so i mentioned cascaded shadow mapping
i'm not going to get too much into this
but you can see that we have different
cascades and this is if we visualize
them it just paints them a different
color
um it just paints the tints the scene a
different color based on what cascade
we're at so the first one is red
uh we can also browse through all the
shadow maps here you can play with like
um
the split of the cascades so this is
like a little bit of a function
or a variable that goes into a function
to determine what the split should be
like i think 0.91 was a good value that
i
decided to stick with and one thing
you'll also notice is that
the seams between the cascades are
pretty good
i mean if you focus in on this area here
like i can't even tell the difference
and this was actually something i worked
on completely in the live stream i did
yesterday
so if you if you're interested in
catching me developing things like that
the live stream is a really good place
to
to um to see me actually work and in
fact
lately i've been posting some of the
development work i've been doing for
hazel on twitter as well so for example
last night i decided to
see if i could quickly get like a depth
of field effect in there and i
posted like a little video of that to
twitter so definitely follow me on
twitter
at the channel if you want to keep up
like with with i guess smaller updates
instead of kind of waiting for these
devlog videos
to come out anyway that's i think that's
pretty much it oh yeah so
there's also a max shadow distance so if
i eventually get too far away
you'll see the shadows kind of fade out
and uh obviously the reason that exists
is because eventually we'll
be at the last cascade and they'll just
you know we can't keep getting further
away
and still have shadows of the same
quality um and so it might be more
preferable to just fade them out
this is something that you can
definitely tweak here and
so if i bring this way down for example
to like here
you can see that they fade out a lot
faster
in fact i might even bring that in more
um
and then you can also can control the
amount of fade so you can see
25 is quite a long kind of fade but if
you bring that down
to like i don't know one or something
it'll
obviously be quite a hard cut off um
even one doesn't look too bad
i think zero is quite a hard cut off
it's just a line
but then if you maybe do two or
something that might be a little bit
better and you can see we have like this
kind of soft transition
to when we are to when we no longer have
shadows so yeah
that is dynamic shadows in our scene
uh it's pretty cool i think uh it's just
the beginning as i mentioned
there's a lot of different um kind of
artifacts and stuff that doesn't really
quite work very well this cube by the
way is i think a little bit messed up
because you can see that i think the
faces are facing the wrong way or
something
uh because the shadow doesn't really get
cast on it correctly i imagine
that um now that looks a bit different
also this stuff is
still of course very raw and very
unoptimized and there's still plenty of
work to be done to make it a lot better
uh oh and one one more thing i'll do
i'll i'll load a uh
slightly better looking mesh because
it'll be nicer i think to
see something that isn't just a sphere
or a cube
and then we can see what that looks like
wow that's big all right let's scale
that
down and maybe i'll just
scale this up and let me
bring back my max shadow distance
okay bring that down
so yeah now we have something i guess a
little bit more interesting in the scene
that's also casting shadows
let's rotate my directional light a
little bit differently
so yeah pretty exciting stuff all right
i hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please don't forget to hit the
like button let me know what you thought
of this devlog in the comments below i
did go a little bit more in depth than
usual so i hope the video wasn't too
long just let me know in general because
obviously i'm trying to make these dev
vlogs as good as possible for you guys
to watch and as enjoyable as possible if
you want to help support hazel don't
forget to go to patreon.com
get access to this source code what you
just saw right now you'll be able to
download it take a look at my
implementation play around with it
break it tell me how bad it is etc and
also catch
all of the backlog of live streams of me
working on this kind of stuff i didn't
stream this stuff too much but i
definitely want to going forward
huge thank you to all of you for your
wonderful support i will see you next
time
[Music]
goodbye
[Music]
you